so The Walking Dead is a comic book
cavitation oh the actual walk how much
of the comic books have you actually
read Oh once I got the role I benched
them I've been to micrantha men um we
had you know I went through as much of
it as I possibly could
trying to find one connections because
I've known from the beginning that Noah
was kind of a hybrid of several
different characters so trying to just
get that understanding but then also
just getting like the tone of it all I
think the show show is a beautiful tone
but that all stems from you know
people's history of the comic so I think
you know it kind of just went it was
just part of my research so The Walking
Dead is actually a the comic book is
actually kind of a multi-ethnic corny is
that something that you really enjoyed
yeah yeah I think I enjoyed that about
the comic in the show because you know
it shows how I guess kind of fickle our
prejudices are you know when you give
everyone a common enemy they kind of
band together and that's what I kind of
loved about this show and the series
that you get the feeling that you know
these people are a family although they
all come from backgrounds that would
directly conflict in any other situation
so that's what Yael is beautiful about
this and they're like you know kind of
just shows how it makes people at least
made me question and several other
people are no question why do you have
issues with other people you know if you
had a common goal those are some of the
same people you would call upon so just
shows how fickle that is if you just get
everybody a common into me okay service
she thing that dad seemed um it was
crazy
two days we had been kind of talking it
over and Stephen and I we're talking
about you know just the ways we wanted
to do it and get it done and we wanted
everybody to feel like they were you
know in that revolving door with us so
that was really it was you know it was
less about the actual death and more
about you know the work leading up to it
I think like you know Greg Nicotero and
then they were always gonna make sure it
was gonna look good we just want to make
sure that leading up to it you know
really broke people's hearts and was
didn't see it coming and that type of
thing and that was like kind of mainly
the work of it
because once you know we got to the
actual death it's just about all the
special effects working right how tough
is it keeping something like that secret
because obviously the so many shows like
Walking Dead where their big moments
aren't they and they want to keep them
under wraps as much as possible yeah you
know I did a really really shitty job at
keeping the quiet honest you know the
interesting thing is as a cast
when the show's airing we talked about
it so I noticed one time particularly
were in LA and we were talking about
what was coming up like you did
something coming up we were just kind of
talking about it and we had to keep
talking around it it's like possibly
people listening to us we're doing a
very bad job it's like you know and next
week is that that thing you know where
that thing happens in there yeah that
whole thing but typically it's spoiled
because people just come home early we
know how long the shooting schedule is
so somebody's back in LA you know but
for me it worked out because I came back
within the same month because there's
only two episodes out but I mean like my
family knew so many people do I just did
a really bad job to keep it quiet
talking about your family is it correct
that your dad's a police officer used to
be he used to be and your character in
Walking Dead is introduced as being for
hostage to a group of us officers did
that provoke any cuts to conversations
yeah you know it did we've always kind
of talked about that whether it be you
know cops in the news or whatever cuz he
also trained cops as well yeah talking
about like you know how when the system
falls apart what is the procedure for
that and um is the interesting thing
about it is he had no idea what I was
doing when I was doing it with
afterwards when he saw it he said no
that's pretty much how it would happen
is it would just kind of fall to
somebody who ya the string of command
was not prepared to do it at all they'll
just kind of hold everybody tight and
all that and end up abusing that power
he's like pretty much that's the way it
would work out so those Dussel was
really cool about it it's seeing that
you know the fiction that we play
actually would probably play out that
way that was in real life
um I mean there's so many people from my
family or you talk on the show or just
you know oh yeah
I think he'll be alright um it's
interesting you know I'd probably go
like family and all that but then at
some point you have to decide or figure
out like who's gonna actually be
detrimental like who love the people
that you love are you gonna save or
actually gonna probably screw you over
and get you killed
something initially family and then like
my strong friends the other ones I might
just put them out of their misery
because they weren't gonna make it
anyway while you're working on the show
was it is there sort of like feeling of
am i next
will I be next Oh times over everybody
has that I think consists throughout the
entire season is not until you know you
get the last script for the season
finale that yeah anybody's called they
must make a lot of tension in the set I
think for some for me you know I never
expected to be there very long
my initial contact was like three
episodes and it just kept getting
extended but after my character
surrounded so much death I knew it was
only a matter of time like you know you
can only get two main characters kills
and you'reyou're not lasting throughout
the season so I like kind of had an idea
that it would come at some point oh you
know it drives everyone crazy the entire
season like it just drives everyone
crazy I think so
you know I think so just because you
have that real aspect of like either I
kind of make this or get this right or
you know it could be coming for me so
that's cool but ya know everybody's
paranoid be from like May to November
nope absolutely not Kirkman has said
everyone will die and I think the ones
that people would think we'll be safe
are actually the most unsafe because
that's the big viewing moment you know
that's they're not gonna kill off
characters that you don't care about
so no one's safe no what do you think
about the fact this is gonna be a
spinoff now fear the walking dead as
well I think we interesting you know
hopefully it'll give us some insight as
to how this thing jumped off how it all
got started
um I've always been interested but you
know with all these zombie projects
what's happening in the rest of the
world like it allows you he's good to
see I'm a little disappointed that they
weren't ambitious enough to go to New
York just cuz I think Manhattan is the
worst place anything like that's gonna
happen
but you know understand logistically
that's impossible to shoot a series
there like that but I think it'll be
good I really do I'm looking forward to
it your new show Colonel mines Beyond
Borders is all about these guys helping
Americans who are abroad you get into
trouble so can we expect to see you come
over to the UK and like bayless oh man I
mean probably you know in in our
backdoor pilot we were in the Bahamas
which is fantastic but yeah eventually
I'm assuming an Americans gonna get in
trouble here although we seem to play
really well together because I think
that's where that show lives is the
logistical issues of getting somebody
out of another country however you know
Britain Americans we play well together
so hopefully they get like lost and like
the back woods somewhere and then we
make it interesting so it's not just you
know that's calling over and you guys
just handing him over it's like right
that was all over in five seconds and
just take you back well I'm you know a
lot of people recognize you from
Everybody Hates Chris which you know you
were amazing and ever loves it in King
myself but what I was curious to know
was what influenced you to change from
coming to them doing something different
um I think just turning it on its head
you know after doing any series were so
long which I'm sure you'll see from
beyond the Walking Dead cast as well you
do something for so long that you just
have to kind of break the mold and turn
it on this head for one your own
creative health into you know your
career would tie past him and all that
you know you have to go the other way
which I'd done like a bunch of dramatic
stuff beforehand before Chris so it's
just like kind of going back to that for
a bit and going you know to the
hyper-real of this show
and is that because like you just don't
want something like people to think they
were just in a way in a way I think this
were like you know a lot of actors get
trapped if they do something that's kind
of iconic and then just kind of stay in
that and that's about it so for me it
was that and then also you know I just
wanted to kind of do something that was
in the comedy for a while I've always
said that I thought comedy was harder
than drama
I just cuz the barometer is so clear you
know with drama you can have so many
arguments about you know whether or not
performance was good with comedy if
you're not laughing that it's not good
so I just wanted a you want different
type of challenge yeah such a young
actor playing a version of Chris Rock
and everyone hates Chris and an out of
comedian and actor who's so widely known
was it kind of very it was it real a
kind of challenge to kind of like embody
a version of him to kind of pick up his
mannerisms and stuff did you work not
necessarily at first because you know we
were kind of playing him as at 13 and
nobody really knew him at that age so it
was kind of mine and just play with as
we got you know further into the series
and I was you know a lot more
comfortable with it then we started
sprinkling some of those things here and
there and I know had we done a fifth
season the talk was to do it like you
know really get really close to it but
we never actually got there so yeah it
wasn't here and there but no it wasn't -
wasn't you know too much they just kind
of let me play with it and find who the
character was at that age and then start
bridging that gap Chris I'm gonna call
you up and be like I didn't like the way
you portrayed oh that's an interesting
way of doing that no you know Chris
wasn't really there that much he was
like you know once we got off the ground
he went off and yeah he thought he was
doing uh I think I left my wife or
something like that
some windows movies at the time so yeah
once we got going you know the
brilliance of that show was really Ali
Leroi who was there with us day-to-day
and just kind of putting in the work in
that way so no not really I mean he may
have thought it would
can you tell us a little bit more about
your new show career Minds and what kind
of tone what can we expect yeah you know
it's it's a it's a lot brighter than the
walking dead and the character is you
know he takes things in differently you
know there's very high-stress situations
I think he takes each one personally you
know I think with all of these
procedurals you know you have to kind of
figure out as far as to carry the main
base characters go how they deal with
that stress and you know he deals with
it very emotionally and you know it
feels like you feel each person is not
saved it's his fault although he's not
out there actually on the fields he's
the one pulling in all the Intel so yeah
it's a different turn you know I think
it's I think it's a little more it's a
little more light but it also you know
has these kind of things they're really
pulling your heartstrings you can get
comfortable with you know it's a nice
kind of comfortable show though you can
still kind of get that emotional work
but not you know that's stressful you
know I have people's blood pressure goes
up when they watch The Walking Dead
maybe you had to compare it to other TV
shows that people might be watching at
the moment what would you kind of say it
compared to Criminal Minds
yeah probably Criminal Minds for now
because we're still trying to find our
you know find our feet I'm having only
done the one episode so as is it's
difficult to say at this point you know
which shows they take on a life of their
own you know you can definitely see that
with the login of like the first season
to now is completely different you know
as Aikido begins to evolve and we really
find our niche so yeah I mean we're
gonna figure it out but I think
naturally we're gonna be you know very
similar to the mothership yeah you've
had such a variety that you've done so
far is that anything that is that any
other sort of genres that you're looking
forward to doing in the future um it's
interesting cuz like so many of the
genres have been like bleeding over into
each other at some one point my career
was like you know I'd love to get in
kind of the action II stuff and then I
was able to hyper dramatic in that with
the walking dead as well
so right now for me it's less about
genres and more about different types of
roles I don't want to kind of get locked
in I'm considering myself possibly
prematurely but whatever more of a
character actor at this point
is that any particular role that you're
looking forward to I like to tell real
stories so I think the only thing that
stopped me from doing that now is like
you know I'm not getting into the biopic
world yet so I think that's something
that I'm just kind of looking at now
like you know I've been building
characters from scratch I want to play
with the idea of you know building
somebody from someone and understanding
who they are so that's kind of what I'm
looking at
next I like you know that'd be fun to
touch on and fun to do
you